foreign
thank you thank you thank you
should Bud Light be sad for making Dylan
feel bad Dylan Mulvaney the trans
influencer who needs beer goggles to
look in the mirror
it's finally speaking up about the Bud
Light Fiasco in a new Instagram video
the Wags slammed the company for how it
handled the whole thing and by thing we
don't mean bulvini's penis
Dirty Minds it's the first time Dylan's
complaining about the Scandal more proof
that he's not a woman
you're right how offensive can this get
but do you really want to know what gets
Dylan's panties in a bunch nope hi
one thing I will not tolerate people
saying about me is that I don't like
beer because I love beer and I always
have I should have made this video
months ago but I didn't and I was
waiting for the brand to reach out to me
but they never did
[Music]
in Bud light's defense they were busy
firing every single employee who had
anything to do with you
now
they even had Spuds MacKenzie put down
talk about a black eye
Dylan claims uh he's scared to leave his
house been ridiculed in public been
followed by people in other words he now
knows exactly what it feels like to be
Brian Kilmeade
that's two now here's more
for a company to hire a trans person and
then not publicly stand by them is worse
in my opinion than not hiring a trans
person at all because it gives customers
permission to be as transphobic and
hateful as they want
I don't remember ever asking a beer
company for permission to be hateful
and does Bud Light or any other company
owe Mulvaney anything after you cost the
company 20 billion why are they supposed
to apologize to you usually to waste
that much cash you'd have to start CNN
plus and then hire Chris Wallace
oh
but nobody should hate trans people for
being different the fact just is Dylan
would be nothing without the recently
released identity wholly embraced by the
media pretending to be a little girl has
made him a very rich whatever
and since when is a company responsible
for the actions of a handful of its
customers I mean when a woman feels too
turned off for sex you know they don't
arrest Brian stelter
it'll never end
all right uh taking you are actually a
real woman it seems to me that we in the
media trans women are actually more
valued than real women does that bother
you does any of this bother you has
everything been said about Mulvaney
that's been said
I
if you're gonna CL like fight back at
bud at least be a about it at
least like just grinding be a real woman
I write and say you know what I made my
money and I'm still making money and
what happened to you you gotta like
shake the Tabasco in the open womb you
have to stand over the ex-boyfriend who
wronged you when you come along and he's
fallen and broken his leg and laugh at
him and walk long and off and not help
him at all you got to be like you got to
be like in that scene of Dirty Harry
when Clint Eastwood's standing over Andy
Robinson and just grinding his heel into
the shot wound exactly it's not a
hypothetical Maybe
oh here's some of it we're committed to
programs and Partnerships and and we
value safety and privacy of and brewing
beer is important and of course anything
you know what you can't even choke down
this dumpster dumpster sausage with the
beer that they made yeah anything that
you say from here on out should just be
belched yes
I had a friend who could do that
I don't think anything ever came of him
but boy we still remember old Steve and
how he could belch the alphabet R.I.P
Steve alcohol poisoning
he got to why well you know
Joe uh when you were watching this and
you were looking at me we were eyes man
you said you you definitely would do
Dylan Mulvaney that's what you said
I I don't think that was the message I
was trying to send
I think it's great how Bud and
Anheuser-Busch has no idea how to react
to this yeah they even they released the
commercial that was supposed to bring
back the old drinkers where it was a
bunch of you know you're at a barbecue
and there's a bunch of men doing stupid
things yeah you know and they're they're
sweaty and then they're cooling off
their vaginas with a nice cold Bud like
no one knows what's what's supposed to
be happening uh yeah yeah this is this
is so ridiculous because Dylan Mulvaney
talking about representing women and
people are looking at they're looking at
you because you're prancing around like
a fool looking like Audrey Hepburn with
a five o'clock shadow you don't
represent anybody this person does not
represent women trans women anybody this
is a narcissist this is a fraud yeah and
you could tell like if you saw them on
the Drew Barrymore show where they're
sitting there praying to each other yes
that's who they worship they worship
their own egos yeah yeah exactly this is
um it's what I think Tyrus you coined
the phrase It's Woman face yeah like
this is not fulfilling all the
stereotypes of a woman and and so it
becomes more like it becomes more like a
Minstrel show or a spin stroll show oh
it's it's a show as well
listen
we got to end the censorship bleeping
thing because you can't you just gotta
leave that in yeah
the boss sleeps at eight we're good yes
not because he's old
um I like that stricter from the record
but
first of all Dylan is playing a
character I think that's the issue that
America is having because other brands
of alcohol I know Smirnoff vodka has
done several campaigns with with
transgendered women and drag queens and
whatnot and there was no issue the issue
is is that and I always so you can't
Woman face maybe you can't get that so
let's just go blackface if Joe put on a
hat backwards and got a little tin belt
and painted his face a little Tanner let
me see Yo coach Tanner and was yo I'm
tireless and this bet yo I got I gotta
rob a bank yo and I got nine babies and
don't pay for him you know some of you
are laughing shame on you but
but you would be like wow man that's
really that's not Talent he's blackface
yeah and everyone's uncomfortable with
that everyone here likes to enjoy a good
evening a black face anyone
see it's not good right so why would you
enjoy Woman face yes where they pretend
to be the dumbest go on the planet
women don't know what's going on in
March yeah who do you think's making us
nachos while we're watching the game
perfect I'm not that's the truth okay
can we be truthful for once he's a dude
pretending to be a girl but he has spent
no time with women so he's acting like
anything he's ever seen on TV or pornhub
or and pretending to be a fantasy and
that's Woman face period yeah boo him
every time he does it
yeah Rob
I think as I was reading the intro to
this I was going in and out of whatever
pronouns I felt yeah you were going back
and forth yes yeah yeah I'm by pronoun
how would you how would you like if you
are you compelled to give the pronoun
or not I I work my way around I'd do
anything but the pronouns yes I try to I
try to say the name oh Dylan Mulaney
this is is this Dylan is this Dylan's
purse no is this Dylan's shoe is this
Dylan's microphone
um I don't know how many Summers the
good Lord is gonna let me have I'd say
12. but I uh thank you fine I've got any
number right yeah I I just I I just
don't want to talk about Dylan Mulvaney
ever again I just don't I just don't
know what's going to happen to me
you know what and you're like because
you're because because Dylan Mulvaney is
the answer to a trivia question five
years from now and I want to get to
there the like remember remember Dylan
Mulvaney like I want to be in that part
right where we're like oh my God yeah
yeah whatever happened in the show Dylan
Mulvaney who like now has a different
career I guess probably five years from
now makes you miss the guy from Slap
Chop yeah right there you go or Clara
Peller oh where's the beef well they've
been asking Dylan that too all right
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else